PETER NORVIG: All right.
Welcome, everybody.
So I'm going to talk about
online education.
And so I'm an engineer
at Google,
but I'm also an educator.
And here I am in the classroom
at Stanford University
teaching artificial
intelligence.
And when I taught this class, I
felt like the subject matter
was pretty advanced
and up to date.
We tried to make it that way.
But I also felt like the
delivery mechanism hadn't
really changed very much
since the 14th century.
This is the University of
Bologna, the very first
university.
And you see we got the sage on
the stage, just like today.
We got the textbook.
And we got the sleeping
guy in the back.
And my class at Stanford was
at 9:00 AM, so I'm very
familiar with that phenomenon.
Now, over the years, there
have been technological
advances since those days.
And so let's jump ahead
to the modern era.
By modern era, I mean 1791.
And "Life of Johnson." Boswell
was writing, "Lectures were
once useful, but now, when all
can read, and books so
numerous, lectures
are unnecessary.
If your attention fails
and you miss part of a
lecture, it's lost.
You cannot go back as
you do upon a book."
Now, of course, that's true.
He makes a good point.
Of course, now we do have the
ability to go back with the
little scroller in YouTube.
He hadn't anticipated that.
But it's still true that there's
a lot of things about
a book that are better
than a lecture.
And so I've done lecturing,
but I've also done a book.
And I began to think
about that.
And here's a passage
from my textbook.
And this is one that my
co-author Stuart Russell did
the first draft.
And I said well,
wait a minute.
That's not quite right.
And then I did a draft.
And then I wasn't convinced
that was right either.
And we had to choose what
to put in the book.
You're only allowed to
put one thing in.
And we realized we are the two
worst guys in the world to
make that choice.
Because it's been a long time
since we were confused about
this subject.
But we know that the people
who would be the best at
making that choice are out
there, but we just lost the
feedback loop.
We know that there are students
who are buying the
book and taking out their magic
marker and highlighting
the important stuff.
And maybe they have a different
color to highlight
the confusing stuff that
they didn't understand.
And they're writing notes
in the margin, and
we're losing all that.
And so we said, well, if we can
close the loop and bring
that online, then maybe
we can get that back.
And we can have rapid
improvement in textbooks.
Here's another diagram
out of the Book.
And it took me a long time
to produce this.
I had to write a program to
munch the data, and then draw
the 3D plot.
And then I rotated the
3D plot until I got
just the right viewpoint.
And then, the poor student just
gets these raw pixels and
doesn't get the learning
experience that I got from
manipulating it.
But I know that there are
techniques where you can have
all this stuff be running live
and the student could get the
same experience I had.
So Hal Abelson, a famous
educator from MIT, was
visiting Google.
And I asked Hal, I'm interested
in kind of the
theory of learning.
What do I have to learn
to get up to date?
And I expected him to
give me an answer of
a big pile of books.
And instead, I got the best
answer I've ever gotten, which
was he said you only have
to read one paper.
And that's Benjamin Bloom's
paper from 1984 on what bloom
calls the 2 sigma effect--
2 standard deviations.
And Bloom says, if you do
one-on-one tutoring and you do
mastery learning, which means
you keep teaching until the
student actually guess it,
rather than until the date of
the scheduled exam, then you
get two standard deviations
improvement on average.
And so you see the
chart moves over.
And if you look at the midpoint
there, it means 98%
are above average.
Almost like [INAUDIBLE].
Now, we'll see a little bit
later that maybe he was
exaggerating a little and not
all the experiments backup
exactly that amount
of improvement.
But the improvement is there.
And this struck home, and it
seems to make a lot of sense.
So one-on-one tutoring seems
like a powerful thing.
I think back in my life,
here I am with my
first tutor, my mom.
And we're going one-on-one and
I'm learning something there.
So I said, can we take that
to the rest of the world?
But I don't really have the time
or transportation to meet
with everybody one-on-one.
So can I get close to it
by going one-on-many?
So I began to try to teach in
that way, teaching not to one
student at a time but teaching
to one video
recorder at a time.
And then, interspersing the rest
of the lessons with it.
So my co-teacher Sebastian Thrun
and I said, it's our
turn again to teach this
class at Stanford.
This time, instead of just doing
it in the classroom,
we're also going to
do it online.
And we're going to offer
it to anybody in the
world to sign up for.
And 160,000 people
took us up on it.
And since then, there have been
others that are doing
this as well.
So Coursera is one of the
well-known providers; Udacity,
edX, this partnership of MIT
and Harvard, and now other
universities.
And at Google, we wanted
to get into it, too.
And the first class we produced
was with Dan Russell.
It was a class called Power
Searching with Google.
It just taught you how
to use Google better.
And that worked so well we were
able to throw together a
system to do that.
Some of the people taking
and liked it.
Thank you.
That we said, well, why don't
we take the system that we
used to build this, and then
clean it up a little bit and
open source it and let
everybody use it?
So that's what we did.
We called it Course Builder.
And last week, we had
the 1.4 launch.
So we're iterating
through this.
There's the URL.
You can just search for
Course Builder or you
can remember that.
It's on code,google.com.
And afterwards, we have five
laptops set up here down in
front and you can come
play with it.
Or you can do it on your
own with the URL.
And here are some of the
technologies, the Google
technologies, that we're
integrating.
So it runs on App Engine.
It's not a Google service, it's
an open source product
that happens to run on a Google
service, App Engine.
So you download it.
You get your own App Engine
instance and you run it.
And you can integrate the
YouTube and the Docs and
Hangouts and Groups and Gmail
and Account Login and
everything else.
And we got a couple dozen
different courses up and
running now from different
universities and nonprofits.
And more on the way.
Here's one example
from saylor.org.
It's a nonprofit that's doing
a bunch of different
courses with us.
We just announced this week,
this launch of another class
following up on the
Power Searching.
There's a course on Mapping with
Google that teaches you
how to use Google Maps
and Google Earth.
And here's just a little bit
more of what it looks like.
So if you've seen any of these
online classes, it's sort of
representative of those.
But you can have videos.
You can have exercises that
are multiple choice and
fill-in-the-blank or other
types of exercises.
And so this is what the
student sees, what the
instructor sees when they're
making the class.
The first version was sort of
do-it-yourself and you had to
be a webmaster.
Now, with this forth
version, we've got
this Wiziwig interface.
And so there's a rich
text editor.
And you type what you want, and
then you can sort of drag
in the various components.
And here, we're dragging in a
YouTube video and a Google Doc
inline and an exercise with
assessments in multiple
choice, or whatever.
And each of these components,
we've wrapped a dozen or so
different types.
And then, we also have an API
that describes how to wrap
other ones, so that you can
have your own custom
components that you
can then drag in.
In one day, one of our engineers
put together Khan
Academy exercises as a
specialized component.
So we just showed how
to wrap that.
And now, if you want--
these Khan Academies
are all under
Creative Commons license.
And so if you want to create a
class, you can just choose the
one you want and drop
it into your class.
So that's where we were with
the first version of Power
Searching and with the
tool that's now
available to everyone.
And so you can use it as is.
And we wanted to do that.
We also wanted to start
experimenting.
To say, do we really understand
yet what's the
right way to make
these classes?
And so we did a second version
of Power Searching.
And there were a couple
of experiments I
wanted to do there.
So first, I wanted it to be more
project-based rather than
lecture-based.
To say, we really want to have
the student's experience doing
stuff, so don't make them watch
a lecture, and then
answer multiple choice.
Just get them right
into it and say,
OK, solve this problem.
There's no lectures upfront.
It's just a bunch of challenges
and you choose the
challenges you want to do.
So challenge number one says
during the glory days of
radio, it was illegal to mimic
the voice of the US president.
Was there actually a law
prohibiting that or was that
just White House policy?
And then, you're on your own.
You can go and try to answer
that using Google.
Or if you want, you can
take advantage of
some of these hints.
So we say, here are some things
you could look at.
You might want to look at Google
Scholar or Google News
Archive, and so on and so on.
And for each of these--
Here was the second experiment
I wanted to do, was saying I
think the first round of these
online classes went a little
bit too far overboard
in using video.
And we heard from 1791 some of
the disadvantages of video
versus text.
So I wanted to offer the video
and the text on an equal
footing and have the students
decide, which one do they want
to consume?
And it turned out, it was
about 50-50, their
choices of which one.
So if you want text,
you get it as text.
If you want video, you
get it as video.
And you sort of watch all
the supplemental pieces.
You can also say, well,
I'm not quite ready
to answer this yet.
Can you show me an example
of somebody
solving a similar problem?
And so you ask for an example.
And here, we walk through the
steps of, oh, if we had this
as a problem, these are the
steps we go through to
try to solve it.
And then when you're done, you
can type in your answer.
And here they've typed in, I
think it was only a policy.
And type show answer.
And then, see the answer.
And in fact, that's right.
It was a policy.
And for a while we were
thinking, well, these aren't
multiple choice questions.
These are almost like
essay questions.
And so do we need some
complicated AI software to
judge whether you got
it right or not.
And in the end we said, no,
we'll just let you judge.
Because we're not giving
you a grade or credit.
So you type in your answer, then
you see our answer and
you say, yeah, I got it
right, or you say,
no, I got it wrong.
But that's up to you to judge.
And students never even sort
of noticed that we weren't
giving them a green check
mark or a red X mark.
They just figured it
out for themselves.
And then, another thing we had
was making it more social to
say see how other solved
the challenge.
So you can click through
on that.
There's a discussion forum where
people talk about the
techniques they used.
I like this guy here.
How did you solve it?
He says, I'm a law student.
I just know.
So not everybody needs Google
for everything.
Now, I should say that when I
got into this, both in writing
the textbook, teaching the
class, thinking about online
education, I thought that my job
was access to information.
If I put down the perfect
information and explained it
in the right way, then
I've done my job.
I also thought that was
true in my job as
an engineer at Google.
So when I was running the Search
Quality team, I thought
my job is when somebody types
a hard query like that--
the movie in which no
babies are born--
then in 0.21 seconds, we should
give you the answer is
"Children of Men." And if we
can do that and the other
search engines can't, then
I've done my job.
But then I realized that that
isn't everything, is just
being able to get the answer.
And I ran across a quote from
Pablo Picasso who said that
computers didn't interest him
because all they can do is
give you answers.
And I think he had
something there.
That really, the hard part is
not coming up with the answer.
I mean, I'm proud of the work
that the Google engineers are
able to do to answer so well.
But the really interesting part,
the part that's really
educational, is that somebody
was interested
enough to ask a question.
And from there, the
answer is easy.
I saw that when we met with
Teach for America.
And we had a teacher who was
given a fourth grade class in
math, two years behind
grade level.
And by the end of the year, had
everybody up to grade level.
So that was three years worth
of math in one year.
And I said, well,
wait a minute.
It wasn't information
that did that.
They had the same textbook this
year that they had the
last year, and that other
teachers had and were
unsuccessful with.
So it wasn't information.
It was more motivation
or determination.
It was this pact that the
teacher made with the student
saying, look, I'm going to
work really hard for you.
I expect you to work
hard for me.
And together, we're
going to do this.
That really shifted the way I
thought about what the job of
a teacher is.
So it's motivation,
not information.
And so the aspect you really
need is willpower to work and
to succeed.
And I thought back to my college
days and said, well,
what instilled me
to get through?
Was it willpower?
And I said, no, it
was due dates.
And so we tried that.
And that seemed to help.
And so we think we did much
better than the classes that
are open that you can
take any time.
Because if you can
take it any time,
you can take it tomorrow.
And if you can take it tomorrow,
sometimes you
never get to it.
And we'll talk more about
the nuances of that.
Then the peer support becomes
more important.
It's not just, can you explain
things perfectly, but can you
talk to somebody?
And can you see, hey, here's
somebody else who's working
hard on this?
I think that's part of what
college is all about is that
it's a social environment where
you see other people who
are also studying.
Well, they're partying, too.
And that's part of
college as well.
But seeing them dedicated to
work and saying I can be part
of that community that's
working is important.
The faculty encouragement
was important.
So every week we sent out
an email that said,
congratulations, keep going.
And every week, I'd get a dozen
or so back that says,
oh, professor, something tough
came up in my work life.
And I was going to drop the
class, but then I saw your
email and I realized
I had to go on.
And I felt like saying that
was a form letter.
You do realize I didn't write
100,000 personal letters to
each of you?
But it works.
So just that level of human
connection, even though it is
a form letter, it makes
a big difference.
I think there's a pride of
accomplishment we need to
accommodate.
This authenticity of this
is the real thing.
This is a Stanford-level class
that I'm taking and I have
this opportunity to
learn this stuff.
I think the excitement of being
in the early stages of
something new has all
contributed to why people
wanted to do this.
And this is just pointing out
sort of the depth of the
social engagement, that people
used all sorts of--
any social networking site you
can see on the web, people
were using that to connect
with each other.
And here I show--
I got this from Coursera, from
one of their classes.
This is a timeline of how
many people are online.
And like all classes, you can
see the superimposition of
three things.
So there's a ramp up at the
beginning and there's
exponential decay over time.
Actually, a lot of
classes have much
steeper exponential decay.
I think this is the one that
Coursera chose to release, was
the one that has a
shallow decay.
And then, you can see
the due dates
interspersed, those big spikes.
And I think there's still this
controversy that I haven't
quite figured out yet of how
important are those due dates?
So certainly, they do make
people come back.
They do make them work hard.
But on the other hand, they
also make people drop out.
If you miss the due date, then
you say, oh, well, now 'm not
going to get a perfect
score and I might as
well just give up.
So I think we need to think
more about what
the processes are.
So I've talked about these.
You can have a synchronous
class, that's the in-class,
Stanford class, that
meets at 9:00 AM.
And if you're late,
you missed it.
You can have these
evergreen classes
that are always available.
The MIT OpenCourseWare, it's
anytime you want to do
it you can do it.
But then you miss the motivation
of the due dates.
Our class we called
semi-synchronous, which meant
there was a due date every week,
but during the week you
could interact with the
materials at your own schedule.
I'd like to get to a model I
call the bus route model,
which says that there's a
schedule and you get on, you
start doing the class.
But if something comes up at
work or at home and you get
stuck, you can get off the bus
and say, OK, I'm taking a
timeout now.
It's going to be fast for me.
I have to stop.
But then you know at some point
in the future, there's
another bus.
You can get back on and
finish the class.
OK, now the big question.
What's learning?
One of my heroes, and one of the
founders of the field of
AI, is Herb Simon.
And he reminds us that learning
is something that the
student does.
And I think as teachers,
sometimes we forget that.
We think it's something that
we, as teachers, do.
And that's not right.
Learning only happens in
the student's head.
And our job is just there
to facilitate it.
And so I think what that means
is it's not how well can I
explain it.
It's how much can
the student do?
And so we tried to make our
class so that the students
were doing the problems first.
And then they would get
the explanation.
We forced students to
make predictions.
To say, here's a
new situation.
What do you think is
going to happen?
And the reason we did that is
because we knew, from the
scientific literature, that if
students have a misconception
of some kind and you give them
an explanation, no matter how
great that explanation is, it's
not going to dissuade
them from their misconception.
They're going to say, yeah.
I got it.
Then you give them a problem
and they still do it their
old, wrong way.
And the only way you get them
out of that is to say, OK, do
it your way.
Here's a contradiction.
Your way did something wrong.
And then they're ready
to think about it.
So we made them make
those predictions.
And I got to say, students
didn't like that in general.
That they said, well, no fair.
You didn't give us
the formula.
I can fill in the blanks in
the formula if you tell me
every step of how to do it.
But it's no fair to make me
think and do it ahead of time.
And I should say, we were also a
little bit clumsy in the way
we specified things, in that we
gave them these problems.
We said, well, don't worry.
It doesn't matter if you
get it right or wrong.
We just want you to
think about it.
But then in the end, we gave
them a check mark when they
got it right.
And so people had been drummed
in so much to say, well, the
important thing is whether you
get it right or wrong.
And that's how school works.
We need to figure out ways to do
a better job to say that's
not the important thing.
Playing with the material
is the important thing.
We like to have experiments with
more open-ended problems.
It's easiest to do a
fill-in-the-blank or multiple
choice because we know
how to grade those.
But those aren't the
most fulfilling.
And there have been some
experiments with peer grading
where you write an essay or
design a project of some kind,
and then have several of your
peers grade it and average
those grades.
It turns out that works
pretty well.
Now, I talked with Hal Varian,
who's Google Chief Economist.
And when he was at Bell Labs,
he wrote the textbook on
microeconomics.
It's one of the standards
in the field.
And he was there with Richard
Hamming, who you may know from
Hamming Codes and so on, and Hal
said that Hamming told him
his secret.
That the way you write a
textbook is first yo get
together the problem sets and
the exams that you want the
students to be able to solve.
And then you write a book
that teaches them
how to solve them.
So I think this fits in
well with this idea
of learning is doing.
And when Hal was explaining
this to me I
said, hey, I know that.
In software development, we
call that test-driven
development.
So you write a bunch of m
then the tests fails.
And then you have to
write some code.
And so it's the same
with a textbook.
You should start with a blank
textbook, write the problems
in the back, hit go.
And every time there's a red
mark where the test doesn't
succeed, then you have to write
a chapter or a section
of the textbook.
So I think that makes sense.
I think the one thing you have
to be careful about then, do
you end up sort of teaching
to the test?
So it only works if the test
problems that you've chosen
are the skills that you really
want people to have, not if
they're just sort of
arbitrary things.
So remember Bloom.
He was the guy who wrote
the one paper that
you had to know about.
How much do we trust him?
Is he right that one-on-one
learning is the
most important thing?
Well, Kurt VanLehn, from
Arizona State, did a
meta-analysis of
this recently.
I think this was from
2011 or 2012.
And Kurt says, here's the
conventional wisdom.
The conventional wisdom says--
Bloom claimed that if you had
this human tutor, you'd get
two standard deviations
of improvement.
If you have a intelligent
tutoring system, the sort of
state-of-the-art computer
system, you get one.
And if you just have the paper
and pencil fill-in-the-blank
type thing, you get
a quarter or so.
And that's sort of what's in the
literature, or the sort of
expectations that people have.
But he looked very carefully at
every study he could find
and averaged them all out
and found out it's
not quite like that.
That you don't always get these
two standard deviations
of improvement.
And in fact, the good
computerized systems are doing
just as well as a human tutor.
And the other thing he found is
that it wasn't so much the
one-on-one tutoring.
The more important part was
the mastery learning.
So mastery learning, again,
means you keep on learning
until you've got it, which seems
the obvious thing to do.
But mostly, we don't do that
because we've got a whole
class of 30 or 50 or 200
students, or whatever, and we
got to move ahead at
a certain pace.
So we say, well, we're going
to learn this for
this amount of time.
Then, there's going
to be a test.
Then we're going to do
the next subject.
Salman Khan talks about that.
He says, this is crazy.
So this is like if I was
teaching you to ride a bicycle
and you ride for a while and
you keep on falling down.
Then you'd say, OK, great.
Now we're going to learn
unicycle because it's time for
the next unit.
That wouldn't make sense and you
wouldn't learn to ride a
bicycle that way.
But if we kept at it until you
stopped falling down, and then
with a sufficiently large
box of Band-Aids,
everyone would get it.
And that's what we need to do
for education is let people
take their own time, until
everyone gets it, and then you
can move on to the unicycle.
So I think those are the
interesting lessons from that.
And then there's one more lesson
that I thought was
fascinating, is that--
there were a couple
dozen studies.
Out of all we spend in
education, there was only a
couple dozen studies that went
into this meta-study.
And sort of the canonical one,
the one that people cite the
most has 33 students in it.
So it's like, we're deciding
the future of our education
based on 33 people.
And maybe 10 of them had a bad
day and we got the wrong
conclusion.
But now, we have the capability,
when we bring this
stuff online, we can base
things on 33,000 or 33
million, rather than just
a small sampling.
We're able to collect more
data and get more
feedback from it.
So I think that's exciting.
So the question then is, how
do we get the advantages?
We can argue about exactly how
much, but we know one-on-one
tutoring and mastery learning
are important.
Can we get them without having
to hire a private tutor for
every student?
Is technology the answer?
Well, technology has always
been the answer.
So all these technologies listed
here, movies and radio
and TVs and so on, we're
going to solve
the education problem.
And one of the earliest
examples, besides the 1791
example, is this is Thomas
Edison featured here with
Eastman from Eastman Kodak.
And in 1913, Edison said that
books will soon be obsolete in
the public schools.
Scholars will be instructed
through the eye.
It's possible to teach every
branch of human knowledge with
the motion picture.
Our school system will
be completely changed
inside of 10 years.
And you could take that last
sentence about the 10 years
and apply it to every technology
since then.
And the question is, are we now
at a point where anything
is any different?
Or 10 years from now, are we
going to say, well, that
didn't work.
And now there's a new technology
and that'll work 10
years from now.
So what's different?
Well, if you look at these four
characters and say, what
do they have in common?
There's probably two answers
that you come up with that
we've all been involved in
these online classes.
And we're all involved in
artificial intelligence.
And I think there's something
about that.
That this idea that you can
learn from large amounts of
data, naturally sort of
attracted all of us to say
this is an application where
we can take that
data and apply it.
And maybe make rapid improvement
in education the
way we have in other fields,
like computer vision, in
speech recognition, so on.
We've seen that now is the
time when it's right.
We've gone from having speech
recognition that's pretty
crappy to speech recognition
that's now pretty good.
And it didn't really
take a single
breakthrough or a new theory.
Most of it was driven just
by having better data.
Now, here's the traditional
model of data.
What you get from your four
years in college is a
transcript that looks
like this.
And that works out to about 20
bits of information per year.
Now, here's a consumer
electronics device.
And that's about 192,000
bits per second.
So that's about a trillion
times more.
You also notice that the one
on the left costs more than
the one on the right.
So the bitrate per
dollar is about a
quadrillion times better.
So it seems like we should be
able to do better than the
transcript.
So we should be able to gather
more information, have a
better picture of you as an
individual, both to represent
you to a prospective employer
and so on, and also to
aggregate that information
across all the students so
that we can make a rapid
improvement in
the pedagogy itself.
Now, if you've seen other talks
I've given, this is a
chart I show where I say in
lots of application that
Google comes up with--
in search, in speech
recognition, in image
recognition and so on--
we often have a response curve
that looks like this.
Where we say we apply some
algorithm to a problem and you
give it a little bit of data,
and the algorithm's performing
pretty badly.
But instead of giving up and
going home, you went out and
gathered more data.
And all of a sudden,
the algorithm
starts to get better.
And the hope is that education
is going to turn
out to be like this.
And we haven't cashed
in on that hope yet.
We're just getting started.
Nobody knows if it's going
to work or not.
But I think this is what
we're all fighting for.
Now, last thing I want to
talk about is how you
put together a class.
And this also is
from Coursera.
I asked them, what's your most
complicated branching structure?
And they said, well, we got a
genomics class that's got
these main components.
And then there's a sort of
introductory class that feeds
into that and an advanced class
that follows up on that.
So on the order of a dozen or
two units that are linked
together in this complex
graphing structure.
Now, compare that
to this graph.
Can you all see that
in the back?
That all clear?
You can read those labels?
So this is from Wikipedia
and this is all
the mammals in Wikipedia.
So about 7,000 entries
and a dense link
structure between them.
So very different than
the other graph.
But in some sense, that's
not ideal either.
I don't want it just-- if you
want to learn about mammals, I
don't want to just
give you that.
I want to give you some
guidance through it.
And so what I would like to do
is be able to combine these
two models to say what we really
need is some guide from
a teacher, or some pathways
through this material.
And here I've shown three
different pathways, three
guides that says here's one way
to look at this material.
And it's a branching
structure.
And now you have a choice
as a student.
I could choose the guide I like
and I could stick with
them and follow them
along the path.
Or, maybe I can switch to
another guide if I find I
don't like that one or
if I want more than
one point of view.
And if I want, I can
go off-road.
I can say, well, the guide's
taken me this far, but here's
some interesting stuff
that's off the path.
And I'm going to take a
diversion and follow off the
path and on into Wikipedia.
So I think we want to build
a system that allows that.
Now, the problem is, who's
going to build it?
I want to make an analogy of
something I call courseware
engineering to software
engineering.
Now, in the early days of
software, systems were built
by small teams.
Here we have one guy.
This is Bernstein working
on his chess program.
Here's Wozniak working on
his operating system.
And in those days, one guy or
a small team could build an
operating system.
But those days are gone.
Now we want to build more
complex objects.
And we worked out a system of
software engineering so that a
team like this-- these guys
built a video game.
We know how we can get teams
of dozens or hundreds of
people to build something
bigger than one or
two people can build.
But in education, we're
not doing that yet.
Courses are still built by one
or two people at a time.
We want to find a way to be
able to put that together.
So what's this doing here?
Well, in some domains, the
artisanal product is what you
really want.
So I want a master cheese
maker to be making me my
cheese by hand.
And I don't want the mass
produced product.
And courses are like that.
And I want to maintain the best
part of the courses of
saying, here's this
expert teacher.
They have years of experience.
I don't want to lose that.
On the other hand, there are
other domains where the mass
produced product is
better than the
individually produced one.
And I want to allow us
to do that as well.
To be able to say, can we
combine these experts and have
them build something so that
we get the best of both?
We get this large graph, but
superimposed on top of that we
have the individual expertise.
And that's where we're trying
to be head for, is
to allow for that.
Now, we built Course Builder
and it's a tool that allows
you to experiment in building
your own class.
I don't know how long it's
going take to get here.
But that's why I'm in it.
And so I guess we
got eight and a
half minutes for questions.
And then afterwards, this is
the last session so you can
stay as long as you want.
And we've got some laptops set
up here where you can play
with Course Builder or you
can talk to us after.
So if there's any questions,
you can make
your way to the mics.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was wondering if you believe
that this revolution will
start from the academic level
or from children in schools,
which is another direction
that's being--
PETER NORVIG: Yeah.
So I think there's a lot of
different directions.
So I started with the college
classes because, one, that's
what I have experience
with teaching.
Two, the subject matter is a
little bit more well defined,
so it's easier to measure.
And three, there's no
complicated laws with children
that are under 13 and getting
permission and all
that kind of stuff.
So it was easiest
to start there.
But I think you you're
absolutely right, that there
are other applications
as well.
And children is an important
part of it.
And I think there will be
a mix there of coming at
children through the schools and
coming at the schools sort
of with children discovering
it on their own.
And you're seeing that with
things like Khan Academy,
where there are some places Khan
is the official policy of
schools and they use it.
But there are many more places
where kids just say my teacher
said some confusing today
and I didn't get it.
But I think it had the word
binomial theorem in it.
And so let me see what Khan has
to say and that will be
more clear.
So we'll see that.
And we'll also see other uses.
So we'll see on-the-job
training, I think will be
important-- continuing
education.
And I think we'll see
non-academic subjects.
How do I fix my toilet
when it breaks?
We'll see better education for
things like that as well.
AUDIENCE: The magic
of YouTube.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name's
Michael Richardson.
I work with [? EasyPREP ?].
We're an educational company.
And our emphasis is actually
on standardized testing and
the scoring aspect of it.
And I'm trying to move us into
the digital age and get away
from the paper aspect.
But traditionally, there's been
a challenge there where
testing on the computer is seen
as being very different
from testing on paper.
Based on your experience, do you
see that continuing to be
an issue with the generations
that are coming up with the
computers and the tablets
the same way it
has been in the past?
Or do you have any words
on that issue?
PETER NORVIG: So that's
a good point.
I mean, I think you want
to be fair to everyone.
You don't want to disadvantage
someone by saying you have to
take this test using technology
that you're not
familiar with.
But I think the technology that
we're also already using
of filling in little bubbles
on a piece of paper, that's
not a very natural thing
for people to do.
That's something that
you had to learn.
And so I think replacing that
with learning to use a
computer is fine, as long as
everybody has access to
training for it and it's not
you're ruled out because
you've never seen
a mouse before.
I think maybe tablets have a
smaller learning curve and so
that mitigates that
to some degree.
And you'll just start to see
more and more kids growing up
and being more familiar
with the technology.
And they'll think it's odd to
be using paper and pencil
rather than using computers.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name is
[? Dario ?] from Argentina.
My question is related
to children.
Beside the legal problem dealing
with small children,
do you think there is a
different [INAUDIBLE]
of education because in
university you want to learn
the thing that the teacher
wants you to learn?
And it's more like a guided--
there's a lot of things to
learn, but it's more like a
definite path for
the learning.
In children, I think it's more
like knowing the world.
There is experiences with
ungraded classrooms and
self-guided learning.
Do you think it's a different
[INAUDIBLE] of learning that
can or cannot be covered with
this kind of infrastructure
for learning?
PETER NORVIG: Yeah, I think
that makes a lot of sense.
That in a college class, we're
able to break up the world
into curricula in a more
well-defined way.
Whereas, for younger kids, I
think you expressed it well.
That there's lots of directions
that they could go
in and it's not that every kid
has to follow the same path.
And that's part of the reason
why I want to have the tools
to be able to build
up this stuff.
I think it would be a shame to
show a kid use this online
tool and there's only one
linear path through it.
And every kid has to follow
the same path.
I think that doesn't
make sense.
Maybe it makes sense for
differential geometry, but it
doesn't make sense for a kid.
And so if you want to give them
that, it's got to be more
you're giving them a playground
that they can
explore in.
It's got to be this dense
graph-like thing where they
can go in the direction
they want.
And I think also that
we want to think of
this as being a tool.
It's not like it's
a replacement.
It's not like they don't
have school.
They don't have teachers.
They don't have anything else,
they're just stuck
in front of a screen.
It's like this is one more tool
and they have books, and
finger paints, and
everything else
they have in the classroom.
And this is one more thing for
them to play with part of the
time, but not the only tool.
AUDIENCE: Hi there, my name
is Jarom McDonald.
I'm the Director of Digital
Humanities at Brigham Young
University.
And myself, growing up with
technology and being in the
development world as well, a
lot of what you talk about
makes sense.
But having academic training in
the humanities and working
with humanities faculty on a
regular basis, I encounter a
lot of general technophobia
anyway.
And over the past year and a
half, as we've been discussing
issues of the types of things
you're talking about, there's
a lot of resistance we encounter
among literature
professors, professors of art,
history, and so forth.
And I was wondering, whether
from your personal kind of
outlook and paradigm, or even
from actual experience, what
sorts of things you might have
to say in terms of the ability
to handle the types of problems
that humanities
education is dealing with,
specifically literature, art,
and history.
PETER NORVIG: Yeah.
So there certainly have been
classes that do that, that
have worked out well.
I think it's required a lot
of work on the part of the
creators of the class
in order to do that.
So it's much easier to do a
math class because I can
generate an infinite number of
subtraction problems for which
I know the right answer.
And generate them randomly
and test students
and get that right.
I can't do that for an infinite
number of essay questions.
The social structure of the
class is different .
It has to not just be you watch
something and then you
fill in the blank and it's
automatically graded.
Rather, it has to be you're
collaborating with other
people, you're talking
with them.
They're grading you're essays
and you're grading theirs.
And you're having discussions.
Sort of the structure of the
class is more complex.
But I think it can be done and
I think there are advantages
to doing that.
That you can have more immediate
feedback that way.
And you can maybe reach
more people.
So it's this--
the paragon of liberal
education, where you have a
small seminar with an expert
teacher and 10
students at a time.
That's great, but
it's expensive.
And if we can get close to that,
but be able to do many
more than 10 students at a time,
I think that's something
worth considering.
AUDIENCE: My name's Wyatt
Anderson and I work for an
education company.
I'm not an educator, but I've
been told by some that
learning is most effective
when directed by experts.
I've been inspired by Coursera's
talks and by
everything else that we've seen
at Google with regard to
the social space.
And we're trying to integrate
more of a social experience
into our learning.
And I'm wondering, what kind of
challenges do you see with--
when you integrate a social
experience into the sort of
like online coursework system
with regard to the efficacy of
the course.
What benefit to the
effectiveness of the education
do you see that sort of
social interaction
with your peers providing?
Do you think that's a valid
direction for education?
PETER NORVIG: Yeah.
I think we still have to
understand how best to use
these social interaction.
So I did my class and I go on
the discussion forums and I
say, oh, wow.
This is so great because
students are asking questions.
And I thought I'd have to
log on and answer them.
But before I can even log on,
somebody else has answered
them and they've given
a really good answer.
And so it seems like a very
lively place and a lot of
participation.
So that seems very satisfying,
until you do the math.
When you say out of all of the
students in the class, how
many are participating?
And you see, oh, it's only
1% that are doing a lot.
And then another 5% that
are doing a little.
And most of them are doing
almost nothing.
So we've found a way to be very
effective for a small
number of people, but it doesn't
yet serve everybody.
And I think we're experimenting
with different things.
So there's a trial we're doing
with Coursera now to assign
students into smaller
study groups.
So the one large discussion
forum is great if you have a
question at 3:00
in the morning.
Somebody's likely to be able to
answer it in a few minutes.
But it's also nice to say, well,
you're assigned to this
group of 10 people.
And you're a study group and
every week you're going to
have a Hangout.
And you're really responsible
for preparing
and showing up there.
You feel much more pressure to
show up and perform when
you're 1 of 10 people than
when you're 1 of 10,000.
And there may be multiple sizes
of groups in between
that we need to experiment
with.
I think we don't know
yet what works best.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
My name's [INAUDIBLE].
I come from a company
called [INAUDIBLE].
We are currently building a
virtual science lab/tutorial
system for developing countries,
especially
targeting rural areas where
they have no internet
connection.
So we have built a system
that is online.
It works online, but it also has
to have the sort of proxy
mode, a small box, [INAUDIBLE]
based, that works in
these areas that
have absolutely nothing.
Now, I know it in Google,
offline is
probably a swear word.
But is there anything in the
education initiative to focus
on those rural areas as well?
Because this is all fine, but we
have a huge group of people
that have no access to
everything you've
been talking about.
PETER NORVIG: I think that's
a good question.
I think most of the time,
Google's policy has been we're
inventing the future, so we're
imagining a future where
everybody has connectivity.
And we're building
towards that.
And if we go in that direction,
eventually it'll come.
We're skating to where the
puck is going to be.
And I think we should keep
following that, but I think
you are right, that there are
places now where people don't
have that connectivity.
It would be good to help them.
One of the guys on my team just
spent some time at the
South Pole.
And there are times of the
year when they lose
connectivity because there's no
satellite overhead in the
right place.
And he said, wouldn't it be
great if I had a Google
appliance on-site that could
then serve as a proxy for
everybody locally?
And that would be good product
for people who lose
connectivity, but we haven't
built that yet.
So I think we're experimenting
with that.
There certainly is a lot of
stuff you can put on tablets
and so on, and pass
those around.
Alfred, did you have
something to add?
AUDIENCE: I'll just
make one comment.
So google.org is focusing on
a few major activities.
And one of them is trying to
provide better access to
telecommunications.
So that's something that we're
really interested in because
you're right.
That without telecommunications,
it'll be a
big problem.
And it's hard to come up with
specialized solutions for
areas when it's not commercially
viable.
To just do something special for
some area, it's not going
to work so well for them.
So we're much better off if
we can find a way to get
telecommunications.
So I think it's more feasible
than not for large parts of
the world now.
And we're working on it.
Some of the things we've even
learned with Google Fiber in
the States and doing these
things cheaply are actually
fairly relevant.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm John.
I'm just a developer
who's interested in
this sort of stuff.
So one of the things that you
really seemed to focus on is
just the general state
of educational books,
software, et cetera.
But it kind of is apparent,
especially from the Coursera
graph you showed, that the
motivation you're creating for
people's really artificial.
You're just making due dates to
kind of keep them compelled
as opposed to making the
information that they're
learning really interesting
to the individual
and motivating them.
Have you guys done any work on
just trying to create problem
sets that appeal to just general
groups of the populace
in order to motivate them that
way, instead of just guilt
tripping them into--
guilting them for not
learning more?
PETER NORVIG: I don't know if
guilt tripping is really the
right way to look at it.
Because this is something
that they want to do.
It's just a question of exactly,
how do they do it,
and how do they fit into
the rest of their life?
So we're not forcing them
to do anything.
They haven't paid any money
for these classes.
They could drop out
at any time.
So the fact that they don't
drop out means this is
something they really
wanted to do.
But they needed the motivational
structure to
figure out when to do it
and when to fit it in.
And the benefit of having the
due date is now when you go
into the discussion forum, you
get an answer right away.
Because everybody
else is online
working on the same thing.
So I somewhat sympathize with
this idea that it's a false
motivation.
But there's also a real
motivation of camaraderie, of
saying we're all in this
together and we're
doing it right now.
And I think that part
is genuine.
Now, can you have it so that
we don't need any of these
dates and people just want
to come back and
do it on their own?
And people talk about that.
There's talk about
gamification.
If people are so excited about
playing video games and they
don't need due dates to play a
video game, can we do the same
for education?
I think that's worth trying
to understand better.
And people talk about putting
in all these badges and
points and so on.
And people get motivation
for that.
That's a little bit different
than due dates, but it's also
external rather than internal.
I think the reason people get
excited by video games is
because they're doing something
that's epic.
So it's not that you get the
badge, it's that, hey, I saved
the world from aliens.
How cool is that?
Yeah, I do realize they
weren't real aliens.
But it's the fact that I
participated in something
great that keeps me coming
back to want to
play the video game.
I think we have to make
education like that.
And I think part of it is having
them do real stuff.
So I said education is about
you doing something rather
than listening to something.
And if we make you build
something cool, then I think
people will want to come
back and do it.
I think they get turned off when
they say I have to answer
a question about this train's
going 10 miles an hour and the
other train's going
20 miles per hour.
And when I'm done, I haven't
accomplished anything.
I know everyone's done that
problem before and I'm not
proud of having done it.
But if we can give them things
where at the end, hey, I built
something that's really cool.
That I can share with my friends
and that I can be
proud of having built, then I
think you'll get people coming
back for the intrinsic reason.
AUDIENCE: Hello, my
name is Josiah.
I work as a professor at the
University of Paris.
Aren't you a bit afraid
of something?
The humanity has proven to be
able to keep books on shelves
for hundreds of years.
It has also proven to be able
to lose, for instance, the
source code of [INAUDIBLE]
40 years ago.
Aren't you a bit afraid to see
all this material lost?
And maybe with these kind of
tools we are building a new,
great Library of Alexandria
that is bound to disappear
with all those wonderful things
that has been lost.
PETER NORVIG: Yeah, so that's
a great question.
Now, of course, the Library of
Alexandria didn't fare so
well, either.
So centralizing all your
paper in one place
is not a good strategy.
So it's better to have it
decentralized and stored in
many places.
It's also good to have it stored
in a format that's
going to persist.
And so why would this
fail to persist?
Well, one reason would be
that formats change.
So whether it's a physical
format, it was on a USB drive
and we moved on and we don't
have USB drives anymore.
That would be a problem.
I think that's becoming less of
a problem as we have these
cloud services and things are
reproduced everywhere.
And you don't worry so much
about the physical format.
So then it becomes more
the data format of,
is this going to--
standards going to change and
JPEGs, or movies, or whatever,
are no longer needed.
I guess there you just need
documentation of past standards.
That will live for a while.
I don't know if the JPEG
standard is going to be used a
hundred years from now, but I'm
pretty sure if a hundred
years from now you gave me
a JPEG, I could find the
definition of what it
was like and write
a translation program.
So I'm not so worried
about that.
And then the other thing to
worry about is the end of
civilization.
If there is no electricity, then
I can't run this program.
Whereas, like the paper stuff
would probably still persist.
And I guess we should
worry about that.
But if that happens,
we got bigger
problems to worry about.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name's Dylan.
I used to be a teaching
assistant at Tech for a really
long time, teaching computing
to engineers or people who
weren't specifically in the
study of computing.
And you talked a lot about how
we can use computing to make
education better.
But what are the things we can
do to make education of
computing better, especially in
our younger age groups or
with female demographics?
PETER NORVIG: Yeah.
I think there's a lot of
efforts there now.
And I guess keep experimenting
is the right way to do it.
Figure out what works.
Figure out, are there
things that are
intimidating certain groups?
Are we doing things wrong so
that we're excluding part of
the population?
I think also some of it is
that it's just hard.
I ran into Don Knuth recently
at an event.
And he had famously said that
he thought that only 2% of
people could be programmers.
And I asked him if he still
thought that and he said yes.
But I think maybe his standards
are just too high.
Because if you think of,
well, how many people
can play the piano.
Is the answer 2% or is
it something else?
Well, it depends on what
you mean right.
So I can play "Chopsticks."
Alfred can
play the piano well.
And other people can be
a symphony player.
And where do you draw the line
between who is a piano player
and who isn't?
So I think we can get a lot more
than 2% up to the sort of
core competency of, yes, I can
bang out a tune, even if I'm
never going to be a professional
at it.
And maybe we should put more of
our focus on that, rather
than just saying, can we hire
more people to have this as a
professional job?
I'd rather focus on, can we get
more people having a basic
understanding, so that they can
apply that to the rest of
their life?
And there, I think it's got
to be a lot more than 2%.
I don't know if it's 50%,
or 80%, or 95%.
But I think we can get most
of the people there.
And I guess we're going
to have to stop now.
I'm sorry, we don't have time
for more questions.
[APPLAUSE]